des contes pour enfants lu par une drag
queen c'est ce qui était au programme
d'une activité organisée par une
municipalité de la Rive-Sud de Montréal
le 2 avril dernier jusqu'à ce qu'une
manifestation force son déplacement dans
un lieu tenu secret loin d'être
anecdotique c'est incident là reflète la
montée en puissance d'une vague de
contestation qui nous vient du sud de la
frontière et pour bien comprendre les
motivations et les dérives potentiels de
ce mouvement bah il faut d'abord
s'attarder à la petite histoire derrière
cette colère qui ratisse bien plus large
qu'on pourrait le penser
Nicolas à notre échelle à nous la
question de l'heure du compte avec une
drag queen c'est tout récent on a
l'impression que dans l'oeil médiatique
ça fait depuis le mois d'avril il y a eu
l'heure du compte à Sainte-Catherine
dans une bibliothèque de cette
municipalité du sud de la ville de
Montréal avec barbada de Barbade avec
des manifestants qui se sont pointés la
tête est présent qu'est-ce que tu as
constaté faut noter que lors du compte
drague c'est pas nouveau nécessairement
barbadof essaie depuis 2016 il y a eu
des contestations au fil du temps des
pleins des annulations de performance
mais c'est la première fois qui est
vraiment une manifestation à cet échec
là au Québec on voit Radio-Canada il
tente d'avoir des images
des sédentées pour les faire mal
paraître vous n'avez pas le droit de
protéger vos enfants contre les
pédophiles de notre perspective à nous
Nicolas celle des décrypteurs ce qu'on a
pu remarquer assez rapidement c'est que
les personnes qui militaient ardemment
contre les mesures sanitaires au plus
fort de la crise de la pandémie ce sont
les mêmes personnes maintenant qui qui
se recycle en quelque sorte dans cette
dans cette activité militantes contre
les heures du conte faites par des
jacquennes mais exact il suffit de
regarder l'événement facebook pour la
manifestation et c'est mobilisations
Montréal qui est derrière ça et
s'organisation là organisé une tonne de
manifestations contre les mesures
sanitaires et justement le principal
organisateur de cette manifestation à
Sainte-Catherine c'est François amalga
c'est un militant anti-vaccin
anti-mesure sanitaires bien connu là il
y a cumuler 98 000 dollars d'amende pour
avoir enfin les mesures sanitaires avant
de la pandémie il était là il était sur
place et avait au moins deux autres
leaders de ce mouvement là qu'on a pu
apercevoir à la manifestation chez les
manifestants aussi on a vu des choses
comme des drapeaux avec le visage de
klauschwab le fondateur durant mécanique
mondial qui est au centre de toutes
sortes de théories du complot dont le
Great reset qu'on a déjà parlé ici des
personnes qui a des casquettes contre le
passeport vaccinal donc on voyait le
code QR comme pot de cuillère ou encore
des gens avec des drapeaux qui disaient
non à l'identité numérique donc comment
des thèmes qu'on entendait dans la
pandémie mais bon sans étiqueter tout le
monde qui était là sans faire de procès
d'intention aux manifestants une chose
qui est sûre c'est que plusieurs des
leaders anti-mesure étaient là et parle
beaucoup beaucoup des drag queen sur
leur plateforme c'est ainsi ce qu'on
voit François depuis quelques mois c'est
une accélération de nagenda qu'on
pourrait appeler pédophile ou
protopédophile où on sait où l'État
s'intéresse beaucoup à la sexualité de
nos enfants comme tu dis le gouvernement
est derrière ça parce que on se rend
compte que depuis quelques temps c'est
comme si on a ouvert un trou et les rats
sont sortis c'est à dire que les dragues
qui ne sont partout sont payés par le
gouvernement il y a quelqu'un qui a un
agence le gouvernement paye un agence
qui il y a quelqu'un là qui s'occupe de
recruter des drag queen là c'est clair
c'est organisé le Big broder en arrière
et le gouvernement est en arrière de ça
là après deux générations il y en aurait
pu parce qu'il se reproduisent pas donc
à l'intérieur d'une ou deux générations
il y aurait plus aucun guide sur terre
parce qu'il y a juste les hétérosexuels
qui se reproduisent les les gays vont
vont être amenés à disparaître et c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont besoin de créer un
mouvement et dans doctriner
les enfants on peut juste demander en
quoi les mesures sanitaires et les
heures de compte drague sont liées le
liés me semble pas très évident mais
sinon des experts à qui j'ai parlé ils
sont pas nécessairement surpris parce
que cette période de la covid les
mesures sanitaires nous vendent
contestation ça fait plusieurs
mouvements ensemble autour d'une seule
cause c'est-à-dire une cause
anti-système une cause
anticouvernementale qui c'est un peu
métamorphosé en cause en typographie et
on pourrait même dire conservatrice
réactionnaire et ce que les experts me
disent par rapport à ce moment-là c'est
qui peut changer de discours un peu au
gris de l'actualité la façon dont
l'écosystème c'est structuré c'est qui
est apparu depuis quelques années ce
qu'on pourrait appeler un écosystème de
droite réactionnaire et où finalement on
se saisit un peu de tous les sujets
d'actualité pour faire passer des
messages qui sont anti progressistes
pendant la pandémie c'était beaucoup la
question justement du contrôle de sur la
vie des citoyens tout ça les mesures
restrictives et puis une fois que ça ça
a été aboli ben souvent c'est les mêmes
militants qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans
les manifs bon qui s'opposent à la
présence de Drag Queen dans la
bibliothèque pour lire les comptes à des
enfants quand on a la on analyse les
mouvements sociaux on appelle ça c'est
souvent sur un changement d'objet en
fait donc je demande c'est quand il y a
un enjeu qui un nouvel enjeu qui émerge
puis qui commence à prendre plus de
place ou à devenir plus important par
rapport à l'enjeu initial autour duquel
le mouvement se mobilisait donc c'est un
peu ça qu'on observe mais là on peut
penser c'est ça qui est effectivement ça
s'inscrit donc dans un mouvement qui est
beaucoup plus large que simplement cette
question spécifique des drag queen en
fait et justement Nicolas si on parle du
discours qui colporté par ces personnes
qui étaient jadises des figures de pro
du mouvement anti-mesure sanitaire dans
ce cas-ci il s'en prennent pas
directement au drag queens comme tel si
je comprends bien mais plutôt aux
activités ce qui concerne drag queen à
proximité d'enfants j'appelle ça le
cheval de bataille c'est un peu comme ce
qu'on voyait avec la pandémie finalement
les leaders publiquement pouvaient dire
écouter nous on est juste contre la
vaccination obligatoire on est en faveur
du libre choix alors qu'en réalité sur
leur plateforme c'est des discours
résolument antivaxin propager énormément
de désinformation et dans certains cas
se réjouissent même quand des gens
décédaient et que c'était suspectés
possiblement que j'ai décidé là étaient
liées au vaccin donc selon David Morin
qui est co titulaire de la chair UNESCO
en prévention de radicalisation et des
extrémistes violents il faut regarder
plus loin que le discours de surface le
discours de façade c'est de dire je veux
évidemment pas rogner sur les droits et
libertés d'une catégorie particulière de
citoyens je veux juste protéger les
enfants mais quand on écoute bien le
sous discours ça va quand même souvent
beaucoup plus loin que ça il y a
vraiment des gens qui sont juste
strictement réactionnaires qui veulent
qu'on revienne finalement
avant finalement les progrès sociaux
faits sur la question de l'avortement
sur la question de la liberté des
minorités sexuelles etc et puis
finalement en préambule Nicolas tout ça
survient ce dont on parle la Sainte
Catherine dans un contexte où au sud de
la frontière au Tennessee et dans une
multitude d'États américains on resserre
la vie en ce qui concerne les dragons au
Tennessee au criminalisent les activités
de drague à proximité ou en compagnie
d'enfants est-ce que ce à quoi on
assiste aux États-Unis c'est un peu
l'inspiration derrière ces mouvements de
mobilisation anti drag queens à
proximité d'enfants ici chez nous oui
selon les experts à qui j'ai parlé il y
a sans doute un lien entre ce qui se
passe là-bas et ici et même dans le
reste du Canada on a vu dans les
derniers mois que ça s'est également
important je pense qu'on peut
effectivement parler d'une certaine
transnationalisation de ces
mouvements-là
bon on les voit on le voit c'est
beaucoup parti aux États-Unis là on
commence à avoir des le même type de
manifestation au Canada anglais puis le
tout récemment au Québec mais c'est pas
limité là non plus au contexte américain
on en a vu en Australie je pense que
c'était la semaine dernière
donc ça s'étend disons à l'ensemble de
l'Occident ce qu'on voit et notamment en
Amérique du Nord c'est la structuration
la constitution de cette écosystème
réactionnaire il est très fort aux
États-Unis et on le voit aujourd'hui
investir le chant donc de la question
des drag queen parce que évidemment le
Tennessee vient de légiférer mais ça
ouvre la porte probablement à bien
d'autres États américains qui vont le
qui vont le faire donc cette influence
américaine très bien relayée par des
médias alternatifs à droite est en train
finalement de montrer l'exemple un peu
si vous voulez ici au Canada pour ce qui
pourrait se faire également par contre
les experts à qui j'ai parlé sont assez
nuancés faut rappeler que c'est un
mouvement assez marginal ici c'est pas
la même échelle qu'aux États-Unis où
est-ce qu'on voit carrément des milices
armés à l'extérieur de ces événements là
on a une société quand même beaucoup
plus tolérante et ne sont qu'une
minorité faut pas non plus balayer ça du
revers de la mer disant c'est pas
dangereux suffit qu'une personne
seradicalise et pose un geste grave je
pense que dans une certaine mesure oui
c'est tout à fait légitime de
s'inquiéter de ce type de mouvement là
bon ça nécessairement tomber dans
l'alarme non plus parce que bon c'est
des ça reste une frange particulièrement
au Québec qui est très marginal mais
considérant
l'ampleur que ce mouvement là prend aux
Etats-Unis puis de plus en plus en
Europe aussi puis un peu partout en
Occident je pense qu'il y a des raisons
de s'inquiéter